es la imagen que se repite los centros
de salud pública del ecuador
familiares reclamando información de sus
pacientes
mientras que adentro se lucha una
batalla silenciosa
dos mil médicos del sector público
renunciaron o se declararon vulnerables
según cifras el ejecutivo nacional
paul dirige este auditorio convertido en
hospital público temporal donde el
estrés se apoderó de sus pasillos cerca
del 40%
y desertaba o buscaba la manera de tener
un certificado médico para no para
justificar el no estar aquí
los médicos están cediendo la batalla
luego de seis meses de emergencia los
colegas están empezando a consultar en
aproximadamente un 50% adicional porque
temas por temas ligados a depresión
es decir síntomas depresivos tristeza
vital profunda pérdida de placer por
realizar las cosas ideas de ruina culpa
y muerte por síntomas ansiosos es decir
sensación de pérdida de control
control que diego no puede darse el lujo
de perder en sus tiempos libres combate
el estrés intenta sacarle provecho a su
talento para no formar parte de la nueva
estadística y ya tenía que ver la
posibilidad de tal vez retirarme un
semestre del posgrado y justo hubo esta
oportunidad de empezar a trabajar en un
área como bic pues la tomé la tomé más
del hecho por ayuda a mi familia por el
hecho de yo mismo quererme superar un
día más para diego quien guarda lo
necesario
es el miedo por no formar parte de los
127 trabajadores de la salud fallecidos
a causa de la pandemia en ecuador